>> IT LOOKED LIKE A PASS
ATTEMPT.
THEY CUT THE BOSTON LEAD TO
FOUR.
PRICHERT IN THE FRONTCOURT.
TATUM THROWS AND LOSES CONTROL.
THEY HAVE A TWO ON ONE THE OTHER
WAY.
POOLE.
CURRY FOR THREE.
GOT IT.
HIS FIRST THREE OF THE GAME.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT, GETTING STYLE,
FORCING TURNOVERS AND GETTING IT
GOING IN TRANSITION.
WHEN YOU CAN'T MATCH UP AS
CLEARLY AS YOU CAN IN THE
HALF-COURT OFF DEFENSE.
>> EIGHT POINTS FOR CURRY.
HERE'S PRICHERT.
MADE SOME GOOD SHOTS.
WIDE OPEN TATUM.
AND HE DRAINS IT.
>> GREAT PLAY BY TICE TO MAKE
THE EXTRA PASS FOR A WIDE OPEN
THREE BY TATUM.
>> CURRY.
TO PAYTON.
TESTING THAT ELBOW.
IT'S OKAY.
LOOKS AT THE CELTICS BENCH ON
THE WAY BACK.
>> NEVER HURTS WHEN YOU SHOOT,
RIGHT, GUYS?
>> NO, IT NEVER HURTS WHEN YOU
MAKE IT.
>> PRICHERT ON THE BASELINE.
TATUM GUARDED BY CURRY.
SIDE STEP THREE.
SWAT.
AGAIN, A BIG WING.
DOESN'T EVEN SEE THE SMALLER
STEPH CURRY IN THE PICTURE WHEN
HE ELEVATES TO SHOOT.
>> AND YOU DO NOT WANT HIM TO GO
LEFT INTO A STEP BACK.
THEY HAVE TO MAKE HIM PUT IT
DOWN RIGHT.
>> HERE'S POOLE FROM DOWNTOWN.
AND AN ANSWER.
HOW BIG IS IT THAT JORDAN POOLE,
JEFF, PLAYED BETTER HERE IN GAME
2?
>> WELL, IT'S IMPORTANT THAT HE
PLAYS BETTER ON OFFENSE, BUT
ALSO AS LOONEY STRIPS TATUM.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT THAT HE
PLAYS BETTER DEFENSIVELY.
>> CURRY WOULD HAVE POPPED THE
TOP ON THIS BUILDING HAD THAT
GONE IN.
WHITE IN TRANSITION.
HE'S GOING TO PULL IT BACK OUT.
ABOUT A 10-SECOND DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE SHOT AND GAME CLOCK.
TATUM SCORED THE LAST EIGHT FOR
BOSTON.
THIS IS WHITE.
HE TURNS IT OVER.
>> THAT'S THEIR SEVENTH TURNOVER
ALREADY.
>> SEVEN SECONDS TO GO FOR CURRY